prix est décerné à madame elsa triolet
pour son livre le premier accroc coûte
200 points en 1945 le prix goncourt est
remis à une femme pour la première fois
1945 alors que la récompense à existe
depuis 1903 depuis sur les 115 auteurs
récompensés
seuls douze étaient des femmes
[Musique]
goncourt renaudot interallié tous ont
célébré le talent des hommes plus que
celui des femmes
mais alors que faudrait-il faire pour
une plus grande parité
voici quelques pistes évoquées en 1990
et il faudrait peut-être aussi que plus
de femmes interviennent dans les jurys
qui est davantage du jury féminin quoi
faire encore moins que les hommes aient
davantage de sens de l'humour qui n'ai
pas l'impression qu'on va leur prendre
leur place des jurys paritaire ce n'est
pas encore ça dans une chronique de
cette même émission une journaliste
faisait des comptes prix pas repris on
va commencer par le goncourt il ya dix
membres il ya huit hommes deux femmes
le renaudot il ya neuf membres neuf
hommes et le féminin dix membres dix
femmes
le femina justement ce prix a été créé
en 1904 en réaction à la misogynie du
goncourt le prix femina 1968 a été
décerné à l' ouvrage de madame
marguerite yourcenar
depuis sa création parmi les lauréats du
féminin 40 % sont des femmes
pour le renaudot 16% et le goncourt 10%
à noter que des efforts ont été faits
depuis 2000 39% des lauréat du femina
sont des femmes mêmes proportions pour
le renaudot pour le prix goncourt en
revanche c'est seulement 17%
pas de quoi se défaire de son image
misogyne
[Musique]